[Music]
okay
hi i'm abe uh i'm a data engineer at
etsy and today we're gonna be talking
about skyline um of which
i was the primary author and so we're
gonna talk about
how we monitor why we decided to build
this
um
and how how it
advances the art of monitoring
so we'll get started so etsy
is the world's largest handmade and
vintage marketplace
we are based right here in dumbo so this
wasn't too much of a pain to get up here
and um
we have a large stack
we've got a lot of stuff going on
specifically or actually not
specifically at all but
these are some just some of our numbers
of some of the servers that we're
dealing with uh 41 shards
um of mysql 24 api servers 72 web
servers 42 gear man boxes a 150 node
hadoop cluster 15 memcache boxes and
around 60 search machines
and a lot more than that
probably on the scale of 100 to 200 uh
for just for other various services kind
of one-off things that we have
and that's not to mention the app itself
which which is is running on top of all
these machines and all the services that
are actually running on these machines
in addition to that we practice
something called continuous deployment
which is
kind of the new hotness with develop
with devops right it's it's kind of
always deploying every single day so we
deploy around 30 to 60 times a day every
day and we make this really really easy
to do for all our engineers
deploying of course means a lot of
different things to a lot of different
people
in our case and in probably everyone's
case it means taking new code and then
putting it on
your web servers to be serviced
and this can get tricky because
people are always visiting your site all
the time and like in etsy's case we're
always making money every second of the
day and sometimes we're making more
money than other times but we're always
making money and so
we you know if we want to make our
services better we have to figure out a
way to deploy without taking the site
down
and so we have this whole continuous
deployment infrastructure to let us do
that efficiently and quickly so that
when someone has an idea to make their
feature that they own better
they can that day push a button and
deploy it and the whole process takes
about 10 minutes so we're very very
proud of that
of course with this process um it's the
whole point is democratizing deploys
right it's not like you you take your
code changes and then go give it to the
high priest of deployment somewhere deep
in the ops the bowels of the ops
department no everyone deploys
at etsy we have about 250 committers and
not all of those guys are engineers
right we have pms to deploy designers to
deploy
in fact it's so easy to deploy that on
your first day you're expected to deploy
a new code to the web stack by putting
your face on the about page and the way
you do that is with the big green button
and you literally just press deploy and
then it does it and it's terrifying
um and so
you're probably thinking like we've got
hundreds of these boxes right these
servers uh and they're they're hosting
constantly evolving code that's changing
up to 60 times a day uh it must be a
miracle how do we even stay up at any
time right how how
do we not just burst into a pile of
flames uh given that the fact that
there's so many half-hazard ways for
things to go wrong
um
well we optimize
not for avoiding failure we optimize for
recovering from failure
and uh the concept this is called is
called mean time to failure and mean
time to recovery and it lies on a
spectrum right if you optimize for mean
time to failure that means you you want
to never fail again
um that means uh your mean time to
recovery is very very long right so for
example
we really really heavily protect our
credit card stuff that's what all pci
compliance is for because the mean time
to failure there i mean the mean time to
recovery is is really really long and
painful and so it's much less painful to
just optimize uh for
uh increasing the time to failure then
reducing the recovery because once you
lose credit card information you're in a
lot of trouble
however
uh if you're dealing with stuff in the
web stack
that that is is easier to fix like if a
process dies you just bring it back up
if if there's a bug in your code you
redeploy five minutes later and you fix
it and this is this is optimizing for
mean time to recovery so
we we anticipate failure we anticipate
things are going to go wrong we
anticipate boxes are going to have hard
drive failures and that humans
developers are are not infallible and
that they will introduce bugs in the
code despite their best efforts but we
don't penalize them for that
we kind of look at it from a systematic
view
and
uh we try to just make it as fast as
possible to recover once we have
detected a failure
and that last part's very crucial
detecting a failure how do you detect
failures how do you know when
something's going wrong when you have
all these different people doing all
these different things on on all these
different services and and servers and
so to that effect you have to realize
that you can't fix what you don't
measure so we have taken a pretty
hard-line stance on just measuring every
single thing
in our infrastructure
and um to do that we've got a bunch of
tools that uh some of them you may be
familiar with and some of them you won't
be so on the not homemade side we use
ganglia for a more deep operational
level metrics graphite for as a time
series database to store our time series
nagios for alerting
we use statsd which you might probably
should probably know about which is um
uh
an aggregating demon right so we'll go
into it in a bit um supergrip which i'll
explain and then skyrim oculus which is
what this talks about so we'll start
with um the most basic defense
super grab so super grip is a really
really really simple
tool that
it allows us to detect errors when they
occur and all it is is a node app that's
tailing log files literally it's it's uh
tail f uh access dialog for your apache
access logs and everything else logs
that you want um pipe grep dash v minus
the things you already know are gonna
happen error like you're searching for
error or failure or whatever whatever
indicate whatever indication failure
that there are in the logs and then
you just load this up in your web page
and then this just goes streaming by and
then when there's an error there
since the whole site is being trafficked
very heavily like the entire page was
flood red with the error and you'll know
something's wrong and so the etsy
parlance for that is is super grip angry
or super grip blowing up and so this is
a really really simple way to know if if
if there are errors being thrown right
because when there's and then when there
are errors being thrown you can go fix
them and uh that's how we do it so after
you push you kind of go hang out with
super grip and you look to see if
everything looks good and then you have
more confidence that your your push
didn't break everything
but that's not really enough because
there are certainly many ways for
a service to break and to be not
functioning and to be felt without it
throwing a specific
error telling you that it's filler um
there are a lot more subtle ways for
things to go wrong and so for those
um one of the ways we handle that is
through statsd
so what we do is sets d and this is the
the mythical monitoring desk that i
refer to in the abstract for the talk
um is
it's it's it's also pretty simple to
note it's a 300 line node file and it
sits there and it listens for pings to
it and these pings look like this in
your code so you're sitting there and
you do something in your logic and then
when you do that thing again you can
call stats data increment whatever your
metric is with the name space in there
and we have a bunch of different ways to
the there's increments there's gauges
there's counters like there's a bunch of
different kind of ontologies for stat c
metrics but they all basically do the
same thing and the purpose is to graph
metrics that otherwise would not be
graphed by super grip
or or by ganglia right so these are lots
of application level stuff
um but not necessarily like you can
throw it anywhere there's code running
you could throw a stats d call and then
it'll instantly it'll get aggregated by
the statsd daemon waiting on one box and
then it'll get sent and flush to
graphite and so with one line of code
you've got an entire historical graphite
series from that point forward right and
then once it's in graphite uh you don't
have to you like rollups are taken care
of aggregation is taken care of you get
all these graphite functions you can
have a graph of the data you can take it
out and
have json and do all this great stuff
and so
all that comes from just the stats
integration
and so like i said before uh this logic
comes from this this philosophy of if it
moves graph it right if anything is
moving in our infrastructure you want to
graph it even if you don't think it's
important even if you don't think it's a
business level metric that could
possibly ever impact failure uh you want
to graph it because you don't know
what's going to happen
uh and even it doesn't move you still
want to graph it like put us that's the
color because it's so easy there's no
friction to do it and that's by design
there's zero friction
and so this way we have uh just metrics
infiltrating everywhere in our stack
and so
once you have those metrics you put them
into dashboards uh we do have an open
source dashboard framework it's nothing
special it's just um it's a wrapper
around graphite and what we do with that
is each team
has the ability to make their own
dashboards
where they kind of cherry pick the most
important metrics that they think are
relevant to them and put them in
dashboards for easy access and so that
that was the flow before
uh skyline and of course
when you just have dashboards the
problem with dashboards is that when you
have an avalanche of metrics like we
have when you have um and the specific
number is a quarter million stacks b
calls and ganglia
and a couple other metric name spaces um
that's that's a quarter million total
which is an absurd amount it's it's way
too much for dashboards right and we've
got 250 committers um if ever if we were
to have you know every committer looking
at graphs all along that's a that's a
dashboard to engineer ratio of one to a
thousand right you'd have to have all
your engineers looking at what thousand
graphs every day just to monitor
everything that you have metrics for
and um so dashboards don't really quite
cut it at that scale
and so what you end up with is a
situation where things could be
going wrong and no one's seeing it
because a there's no dashboard for it
b if there is a dashboard no one's
looking at the dashboard and so if no
one's looking at the dashboard or
otherwise not aware of this metric
that's spiking or doing something that's
not supposed to be doing
no one can act on it and either decide
it's a failure and fix it or decide it's
normal and not fix it and be it but
but be aware that it that is what it
looks like
um and so to kind of counteract this we
we do use nagios we're very heavy users
of nagios or nachos if
that's how you pronounce it um but um
nagios sucks and everyone likes to say
how much nagios sucks
there's a lot of friction to develop a
nagios plug-in you don't necessarily
always have confidence that your
inaugural plugin works right because you
can write the plugin and then
it'll pass green because you think it's
right um but that doesn't mess like but
you know to test that is wrong you'd
have to take your server stamp which you
can't do so now you've got like a dud
metric that you think is working right
that's dangerous um nagios is stupid
there are thresholds that you manually
set
um and
it you know it's say you've got a disk
space slowly filling up on one box right
and then you have a threshold like 85
alert me when this is happening uh so i
can clean the box up and then nagios
decides to wake you up at three in the
morning because look the disk space is
at 85 now but that's been slowly
climbing for three years like it did not
have to wake you up at that particular
moment
so it doesn't know it really doesn't
know what normal is and what what how it
should structure its alerts and you
can't just tell it to it's that's really
hard
so
um
skyline was meant to
just to kind of take this the next step
forward um and so and of course there
there obviously aren't um
nagios alerts for everything right there
are because we have this whole wealth of
metrics uh and they aren't there isn't
100 metric coverage for nagios um there
is an argument that says you know maybe
you don't need 100 metric coverage like
it's really only good to monitor things
that you know are are like mean things
but
um skyline the design of skyline is to
take the long tail of everything right
to just say everything could be valid um
err on the side of noise and give you
the metrics that
are are spiking and that's all it does
and then it's up to you as the engineer
to act on those if you choose to
all right and so kale is the thing that
we came up with
uh to to do this and it's it's composed
of both skyline and oculus skyline is
the anomaly detection part of things and
oculus is the metrics correlation part
of things we're not going to talk about
oculus today but the way it works is you
can detect you could find a metric and
you can you can see
what other metrics at that time looks
similar to it right by using like
literally how the graph looks uh with
the the logic being if uh something's
messing up probably it's not messing up
in isolation and probably there are
other things that are also messing up
that would help you get a broader
picture of the problem and diagnose it
and then fix it
so
before you can do that you have to know
that it's you have something wrong in
the first place and so that's what
skyline comes in for
so
uh we have a question
uh the question becomes how do you
analyze a time series for anomalies in
real time given this structure
pre-skyline and it's actually pretty
easy
you can just make a lot of http
requested graphite's api right
graphite's got a really really awesome
api that you can hit and get the
perfectly structured json data back and
you can take your json and you can run
algorithms on it and you can you can
just keep hitting it you know once every
10 seconds or so for as many metrics as
you want and
that's the way to do it that was what
the prototype of skyline was
but that doesn't work when you hit our
scale we need a quarter million metrics
because graphite's going to dis to
retrieve historical data and it can't
handle you know you hitting a quarter
million requests for all these time
series every 10 seconds if that's the
resolution you want um it's not going to
happen so you need you need a dedicated
service so that's where skyline comes in
so to reiterate skyline is a real-time
anomaly detection system
uh let's dig into that
so real time uh means a lot of different
things
in a lot of different contexts and in
this context
i'm kind of lying it's it's real time
enough
on two levels so the first level is that
we do a stats day resolution of 10
seconds so that means every 10 seconds
no matter how many stats the metrics
you've received it flushes the graphite
every 10 seconds so you're not going to
get higher resolutions tested data
unless you specifically set one second
but the
the
convention at etsy is to stick with 10
seconds
and gang layout we use one minute
resolution right so you're not going to
get more than one minute resolution you
can you can tweak this but um we don't
do it
and uh so that's what we're doing so the
best case scenario even if you could
analyze process uh and store instantly
is going to be 10 seconds for the right
for the staff see ones and one minute
for the ganglion ones
of course you're not doing just that
you're also processing them right you're
just going to store them somehow and
then then take them out and then process
them on your algorithms and so
um right now it takes about 70 seconds
with our throughput right so
um that's not so bad right that's really
not bad and uh it's it's even better
when you think about that it's still
faster than you would have discovered
otherwise right and that's really where
this shines as long as this is faster
than you would have discovered otherwise
which is in most cases never um this is
good enough and so
at this point we could we could optimize
it right but um
it's still it's an improvement
so uh on to the architecture um when
you're talking about making
all these requests and and kind of
playing with data
um at the speed that we would like
memory is is a much better storage
medium than going to disk which is why
graphite wouldn't work in the first
place because it stores its its metrics
as whisper files which is a round robin
database on disk itself and we don't
want to have to go to disk to get a
certain time series that we want we want
it to be already easily accessible
so we chose redis to do this
redis has a great api it's it's rock
solid
at least for what we're doing with it
we don't use the redis cluster yet which
i don't think is mature at this point
but
it's got a lot of cool data structures
really great community and it's a really
solid tool so we were excited to use it
and um the question then becomes how do
you get a quarter million time series
into redis on time
and the answer is to stream it
right if you could find a stream
and so we looked around
for our stack for a stream of metrics if
we could get them because we didn't want
to have to like
like how are you going to get all these
different these kind of
varied ganglion metrics since that's the
metrics all in this one place
um
we we didn't know what to do but then we
looked at the
graphite and we realized like they are
already going in one place they're on a
graphite and
um
that's cool and in addition to that we
also use this thing called graphite
relay uh there's it's called carbon
relay and it's what it's it's what it's
built for is a redundancy thing right so
you have your your stats d and your
ganglia your stats there's already one
aggregation then it's sending everything
to graphite i think ganglion is sending
everything to and then uh graphite will
take all its stuff and then store it
on the listener now if you do it that
way that's cool but then your if that
box goes down
which you have to assume it will one day
then you've just lost all your metrics
and you're blind until you can get them
back up so what we do is we have a relay
list center so so our streams our statsd
and our ganglia ping to the relay and
then the relay will immediately upon
receiving the metrics uh send them over
tcp to a backup graphite and to the
local graphite listening uh on the same
box so now you've got you've got like a
you're making p t rights essentially two
two graphites and so that way you can
have redundancy and then the way it does
this is it sends pickles over the wire
to the other backup graphite so that way
if one box goes down uh it's no problem
you have another one and you can just
bring it back up and keep going keep
deploying and keep operating and so we
saw this and we're like okay
um
we can just
trick graphite and say instead of
reeling to a backup graphite we can just
relay to skyline right skyline's you
know skyline's perfectly capable of
listening on a port which is what
graphite does and consuming and
consuming data which is exactly what
graphite does so we just simulated the
graphite protocol we would pick a
listener um it's written in python so uh
it's easy to do pickles and then we just
have a listener and the original
graphite doesn't know that there isn't
another graphite listening
right but so it's so what it's doing is
it's sending to to three things now the
relay setting to three things sending to
the original
the original carbon cache listener on
localhost it's sitting to the original
redundant graphite on that box and it's
also sending it to skyline right so
we've got three separate streams but the
the upside is that skyline
now has this awesome
stream of data and that includes ganglia
and genga is also an awesome thing
because
out of the box it can write to rod files
so we've got a script that will go in
and import it from those rd files
cool so we have our stream and it's
going to our box we've solved the hard
part maybe um
now what do we do with the data right we
have to we have to keep it somewhere um
unless we're going to talk about doing
strictly online stream processing which
which we're not going to talk about we
have to store them somewhere to then
take them out and analyze um of the
duration so when you want to think about
doing this uh we're keeping it in memory
we're keeping them in redis and you have
to have two things in mind when you want
to do this you want to minimize both i o
and and your memory footprint and those
are for both fairly obvious reasons
right because i o
um you're both putting things in
consuming them and taking them out right
for for the analysis stage and redis can
only handle so much even though it's
really really good it can only handle so
much um similar with the memory
uh you you have to you know there's a
limited amount of memory you can store a
limited amount of metrics for a limited
amount of duration and you want to get
that as small as possible so you can you
can pack it the most as possible in you
know within your confines
so to do this um
we chose to
store the data as strings in redis and
that might seem counter-intuitive like
redis has a lot of cool structures that
might seem better for storing time
series like
lists for one but the problem with lists
is that
you take them out and it's login time to
take them out which is not ideal whereas
with strings it's constant appends and
constant withdrawals right which is
awesome right and actually that's kind
of a lie strings as they get longer and
longer redis does not does not handle
them well but it's still like
orders of magnitude better than any
other data structure and whereas so we
have to deal with it um and then uh we
use the append so like so you know
normally you would do a get an asset
with a pen it's just a it's an atomic
set and it's guaranteed to be in order
so it's it's super super awesome and so
we we save ourselves uh we cut our gets
in half right we only take you only get
ones when we want to analyze them and we
only set them when uh we want to
update the time series so we have our
strings in redis and now we have to
think about how we're going to structure
because you can't just store
data in the form of strings in your
storage
so
you might think that json is is the
answer and we did think that for a while
um it's fairly straightforward you can
um
you can it's easily appendable right so
say a data point came in and this is our
series
another data point comes in you just
append it on top and then another data
point comes in you append it and then
you have almost valid json here when you
want to take it out you just withdraw
that metric uh append brackets on either
end and then it's valid json that can
then be decoded in whatever language
you're dealing with
um and this this this seemed alright but
we found that over half our cpu time was
spent decoding uh json which is in my
opinion a silly silly problem to have
we want to save cpu cycles for the hard
things like analyzing uh the actual time
series right things that are harder to
be optimized
json decoding is just a kind of very low
problem that
we're above that right
and we can we can kind of look into that
why that is so here's a json uh
a json json data it's an array with two
things in it
if we break it down
um we're realizing that the things we
care about are
in the minority right
we only care about the one and the two
we don't care about the comma or the
bracket but the reason that stuff's
there is because the cpu needs it to
to decode the json and turn it into an
actual object in your language
and the way it does this
is it does a scan like it looks it okay
this is a bracket this is a one this is
a comma so it's a new element uh this is
now a two okay i still don't know what
what's going on oh is the closing
bracket okay is there anything else no
okay good i have an array bam but what
it's done there is it's it's scanned the
entire stream right and there's no
metadata to tell it to skip this thing
because it's stupid or pre-allocate
memory because it doesn't know
and
that's a waste of cpu cycles so
um we looked around for things that do
have metadata in them and we found
messagepack
which is really really awesome and it's
what it is is a binary based
serialization protocol
it's it's in the same class of things as
as protobufs and avro and thrift
which are all they're meant for
rpc right communication they're not
really meant for storage but
they they do solve the problem that we
needed which was
speed of decoding and
and
size right because you want to send
things over the wire you want it to be
as small as possible and you want to be
easily
understood
at both ends so this actually solved our
problem
and uh so we can look at what message
pack looks like
it has metadata and the metadata
consists of headers okay so the header
here is uh that we care about is is the
the size of the array which is going to
be either 62 or 30 big indian integer
that basically tells the cpu okay this
is how big my array is and you have to
obey that obviously but um you just
append your two things on there and then
that's that's a concise thing and so now
the things that we care about are the
majority of the actual data we're
storing we're storing a minimal of
metadata and message spec is also it
also supports appending things right so
you can just append it on um you've got
a message pack now and you can just
unpack that right and
that's really super cool and so the the
result of doing this of switching over
from message back to json is
we cut our cpu time in half
and still it's still a big problem for
us um until something better comes along
we're stuck with this but um
it's significantly better so i would
recommend in just about every situation
were you thinking of using json to use
message pack instead unless you're
dealing with the browser so any but
anything internally there's there's no
reason to use json and it's really a
drop-in replacement and the apis that
people have wrote about message pack
they wrote it with that in mind to just
replace your json with it
and so okay so now um
we've got things coming in and they're
being stored to time series on redis and
they're being appended and um if we let
it do that forever we're going to run
out of memory because we keep appending
and pending we're not getting because we
didn't want to do that right because
that's that's more i o we're pending
we're putting a penny and um it's going
to run our memory so we have a process
called the roomba that goes through
occasionally and it will clean the data
and it will make it get but it runs less
often and so it's kind of negligible and
it'll run through it'll it'll get
everything it'll trim off the excess
duration and it'll put it back in right
and so in this way
we store a continual rolling duration of
24 hours for each metric and
unfortunately we can't go above that
because then performance really starts
to suffer
uh so yeah we wrote this in python as i
mentioned before
it might seem like
like not a good idea to write a heavily
current architecture in python um
but the uh we chose it because it has
really really good math math options
like you know numpy scipy stats models
pandas like this is these are really
lively areas and they're they're pretty
good um and so even though it's not that
great for parallelism and concurrency
we had more faith in our skills as
engineers than statisticians so we opted
to slog through
the engineering uh in in favor of an
easier time handling the mappings so
that was why we chose that um and then
the rest of the architecture is pretty
simple uh we have this so that's the
entire consumption architecture and on
the other side we have an analyzer
it's based on a very simple mapreduce
design
uh it basically
it just
takes i think 30 processes however many
cores you have is how many processes you
should have and then it will
at the beginning of each run assign
all the keys and redis to a process
and then that process is responsible for
decoding that slice of keys um and
analyzing them and everything and then
at the end of the run all the results
get compiled into one json blob uh
that the front end will will go and get
every every couple seconds right so it's
in this way it's refreshing and uh
you're seeing constantly updated view of
what is anomalous and so here's what
that front looks like we'll do a demo
later but just so you get a taste of
what we're talking about here
all the metric names are there
so you kind of go through them scroll
through them the actual data point that
triggered detection is there as well
so uh that's how you know and that's
what the red line is so you can kind of
visualize what the computer's thinking
um a little bit easier and then you get
two views of your metric uh the first
view is the last hour and the the second
view is the last day
and that's just for more context because
oftentimes like what looks anomalous
with an hour um does not look anomalous
when you consider the broader context
and vice versa so you get both views and
again we only store about 24 hours
or exactly 24 hours
cool
okay
so i've talked about anomalies
um without defining what it means to be
anomalous
so
uh the way we handle the actual analysis
part
uh is through a consensus model
so uh the way that works is it's a vote
basically we have a bunch of algorithms
implemented and then each each time
series is run through all those and then
uh they either return true or false this
is anomalous this is not anomalous and
what you get is
if the majority of them
you can set this parameter like if like
six say yes it's okay or seven if you
want to be stricter um we'll vote that
it's anomalous then we consider an
anomaly and then we surface it to you
and the reason we do this
uh is because
it uh it helps for
mismatches within the model with respect
to the time series that you know the
actual data and uh what your algorithm
is running on right um like you might
like one one
you know idea that was proposed was you
know why don't we you know go the the
finance route right and and just make it
a strictly forecasting problem and just
you can do an ensemble of forecasts and
then average them out uh and and then
have that's your that's your forecast
and if it's significantly different than
that then that can be your anomaly but
um the problem with that is that it it
uh
it's it's opinionated and we i mean we
found that like we had so many different
kinds of data like that didn't really
work in all cases and it really limits
you into what you can do
so you can still do forecasts in this
but what you can't do is is get a sense
of how anomalous something is because
they're all different algorithms um
how anomalous something is on one
algorithm doesn't really relate to how
anomalous it seems on the other so
that's one problem with doing it this
way but the upside is that you can
implement anything that you get your
hands on as long as it returns true or
false so we thought that was a pretty
significant upside so that's how we opt
to do this
the basic idea
is
behind the algorithms that we have
implemented at this point is um is as
follows so it's it's a metric as
anomalous if it's the latest data point
is over three standard deviations above
its moving average
right so you've got
you've got your time series right uh
you've got um standard deviations from
the time series which is like that's the
normal variation the normal noise and
then you've got one standard deviation
up and down two standard deviations and
then if your latest data point that
comes in is like up here or down here
right if the absolute value is over
three standard deviations above or below
the moving average
then
um you will be justified in saying that
this is an anomaly and that i want to
know about it
this is also this is this is from
statistical process control which was
invented um in the 1920s i think by a
guy named will short and
it was made
to to because you know this is when um
the assembly lines were coming along
right and you had these huge uh
operations chains and you didn't know
like what parts are working so
you had what they're called control
trucks which are essentially exactly
this like you have normal normal lines
of variation and then when you're when
you're
you know when your screw or whatever is
outside when the width of your hole
that's being screwed is outside that
line then you know you have an anomaly
and you should fix something
and so
um
just to visualize this one more time
here's your here's your regular bell
curve right this is the normal
distribution and your means right there
in the middle so these are these are
data values of data and um when you're
when your data point lies within that
third the three sigma there uh then
that's how you know you've got an
anomaly um
in the best scenario so uh to implement
this we kind of riff on this we kind of
achieve this in a bunch of different
ways um first what we do is by histogram
bidding so you get your data uh here's a
real time series from graphite that did
get surfaced by skyline a couple hours
ago when i was making this live um
and you you take your most recent data
point so that's uh that's 40 there if
you can't really see is that a laser
so yeah yeah you got your your data
point there and then follow that and
that's that's 40. okay and then um
you make a histogram of the entire
uh time series right so this this is it
kind of looks like the normal
distribution right and you can see like
when um like histograms are
distributions of of the data and so when
there are smaller bars that means less
values uh are the the perceived the
value they're calculating so if we look
at 45 on here or 40 on here we said the
bar is really really small right it's
not it's like really that that's in the
the three sigma area of this
distribution here and so
uh to to just check we just check which
bin that data point is the 40 is and we
see it's right there and so that's a
really small bit in size so that's an
anomaly right that's one way to do it um
another way to do it is by a linear
regression all right so take take the
best line if you're ordinarily squares
is a very common linear regression
algorithm and then um so you have your
data again uh you fit a regression line
on it right and um there are problems
with this which i'll go into in a bit
but
bear with me for now so you fit your
regression line and then you take the
residuals which are the errors of of the
mean of your regression line or just the
line itself because this is a data point
too and um
you then take all those
and then
find the distribution of those right and
then you've got your three sigma here
which is your three standard deviations
and that's that would be the anomaly
there right
so that's another way to do it
a third way is through median absolute
deviation
um where you
you basically
take the median of your time series the
middle value that occurs the most often
which is
going to be in the highest bid in your
histogram distribution and then you
calculate the residuals with respect to
that okay so so you calculate how off
every other value is with respect to
that and then you find the median of
that
right and if that is outside three sigma
or whatever whatever test statistic you
want to use then it's an anomaly again
so these are all kind of different ways
to do it i think i have one more here
all right so this is um this is a
broader technique that we want to use
too um so
instead of using averages it's generally
recommended to use exponentially
weighted moving averages
and that's because
uh data like monitoring data
and operational data kind of gets less
valuable as it gets older you know like
you know when we're capacity planning
we're not we don't really care what
our data you know our page views per
second performance time was in 2009
right it's not really relevant our whole
stack has changed and so
we can apply this to to this problem as
well so instead of just taking the
entire time series and using all the
values and treating them equally we can
add the k factor the time series
and then um so that way the most the
more recent values are are treated
more with you know with
with more importance right and so
uh in that way
we can we can know what's normal based
on what's happening right now and not
really care about what's happening in
the past
and so this this discounts the older
values a little bit to give you a little
bit more accurate um and to make it a
little less noisy so that's the
technique and you can apply this to the
exponentially weighted technique um
basically anywhere like just weight
things right according to where they are
in your data
so that's that's one technique but uh
there are a lot of a lot of problems
with this so skyline works but um there
are lots of things it doesn't handle and
uh i i want to go into them right now so
we can we can think about how we can
solve these problems together uh so
these are the four horsemen of the mod
apocalypse they are seasonality spike
influence
normality and parameters
okay so first one's pretty
straightforward
you might think that this is an anomaly
and if you saw that on skyline you'd be
like hey you think skyline thank you for
showing me this awesome thing that
doesn't look right at all
until you look at the 24-hour view and
realize that it is
probably a crown job it's highly
seasonal it should be happening in fact
i want to know if it doesn't happen how
can i get skyline to tell me this how do
i know
um your your regression lines are going
to totally fail here right because the
average of this you take a regression
it's gonna be like right in the middle
right that is totally worthless it's not
going to tell you anything and the the
deviations of that are also worthless
right
this distribution curve is not going to
be a normal distribution
um
so
our algorithms totally fall apart with
seasonality and uh that's that's one of
the problems that we're working on
like and the thing is once you detect
that something seasonal uh it's easier
to build an algorithm but these are very
expensive but we'll get into that
um
so spike influence so when you have say
you detect anomaly and you got your
spike and everything's working well
but then when you're using this whole
three sigma paradigm your moving average
even if it's exponentially weighted it's
being artificially bumped up right so
you have the same problem of having your
average be much more than everything
else just because it's like the tent
effect right and so you'll miss another
anomaly that comes even it like even if
it had breached like say the first
nominee didn't happen
um
it would have been detected if uh if
that anomaly hadn't happened but since
it did the average has moved up
the the threshold for three sigma is
moved up and um you've got you've now
got an anomaly that's that's kind of
slipped by you so that's a problem and
to fix that you have to kind of like
remove the outliers right or kind of
retroactively go back and change your
data we're reluctant to do those things
because we're trying to detect outliers
in the first place right and we don't
necessarily want to change data so
that's another problem
the third problem is uh normal
distribution this is the real real big
one um so real world data doesn't really
follow normal distributions right like
all these all these forms all these
algorithms are kind of like they're
developed and what's what's equivalent
to the data like a pristine data
environment where every everyone's got a
normal gaussian curve and life is dandy
but um
that's like that doesn't that's not true
for for lots of real word data and the
reason statistical process control was
able to get away with it and was able to
be so influential is because they're
they're dealing with fundamentally
different things that we're dealing with
right they're dealing with with with car
assembly lines and with with with you
know screws that have are supposed to be
brought like defined widths and they
have specs they know exactly what they
want and it's very easy to like if you
have a drill bit that drills holes all
day long you're going to have a really
really nice distribution curve because
it's doing the same thing and you know
and you know what it wants to be doing
but we don't have that right we don't
have that luxury um there are no specs
for our systems we we build them because
we have to serve
users you know we don't spec it out uh
we don't like we have no idea what
uh normal is really as long as like
besides you know you log into etsy.com
and it serves you beyond that like it's
it's not in apparent immediate like what
a normal flow of data through the system
looks like because it's a complex thing
and there's different moving parts and
like this this is uh you know this is
the um the disk i08 on our database
right it looks terrible right but our
site's up so
is it normal is it not normal i don't
really know um i don't know i don't have
access to all the data of all the
components that are making that
particular graph behave the way it's
doing so i don't know if this is
actually a good thing or not and as a
result i don't get the luxury of knowing
what is normal
and what is not known so
to kind of reiterate when you have
simple systems like just a drill bit and
a piece of wood you have very simple
definitions of what anomalous is
when you have complex systems you're
very complex editions of anomalous and
that's not necessarily you can't really
reduce that to a simple matter of this
metric is bumping like that doesn't
translate to
your system is failing right and that's
something to watch out for and of course
in addition to you know complex systems
being uh complex uh they even if we were
to nail it down at any given time
they're evolving right because we're
deploying all the time our systems are
changing we're bringing servers up we're
taking them down we're changing the app
code uh we're getting hit with more
traffic because obama treated us you
know like these are things that happen
and we have to be able to adapt to it
and our monitoring has to be able to
adapt to it too right and so skyline was
built so that
it can be adapted like it's more
adaptive than nagios which will just
trigger the threshold but it's still not
enough and we're still trying to think
about how to get it to be more adaptive
and one example of that is
like you know all the time we take out
shards uh to do rebalancing or something
and then skyline will detect that which
is awesome right but it's a false
positive
it's something that we know is happening
um what's a good way to to kind of shut
that off right and now we're getting
into the kind of
the area of alert design right and user
interface which is not the focus of this
talk but it's another thing to think
about
and the fourth the fourth uh horseman of
the model apocalypse is parameters our
parameters
so to kind of back up on a broader so
this is um this is a graph of our we're
doing capacitive planning right now so i
had this graph handy and this is our
page use
for for since 2009 to right now in the
blue and so
um so i i modeled it i wanted to make a
nice prediction and so
i i made a prediction in the model and
uh this is um it's a nice mod it looks
pretty good right like that visually it
looks like like that is what our demand
is going to look like in terms of page
views and um
the problem is
uh this i spent a lot of time making
this model and kind of custom fitting
the model to data making sure my
assumptions were good um fitting my
parameters right and and you know what
parameters in general uh that's kind of
a term that you might see get thrown by
like parametric versus non-parametric
in general so when you say something is
parametric um it's like not machine
learning right because machine learning
and i could be completely wrong about
this because i don't do much machine
learning but machine learning is when uh
you you just say like machine figure out
what the best model is right and figure
out what parameters you need and what
those values should be whereas with
parametric models
you set the parameters right so these
are these are like different gauges of
your model that you set to fit it the
right way so the parameters for this
model that i had was that it was
seasonal right so i had to say like okay
treat every data point on a 365 day
season right so only compare it to the
data points 365 days ago um
give a certain amount of weight to the
overall trend but also a certain amount
of weight to the seasonal trend right
like these are different kind of impacts
um give it a an exponentially weighted
smoothing factor to kind of discount the
older data and do all these things um
and then once you have all that once
you've defined your parameters
you want to fit it we do do a bit of
machine learning this is like the most
basic
the most basic application of machine
learning where you train the data so
basically
run it against all your different
parameters until it finds the lowest
root mean squared error right so until
it fits the most and then there's your
model right and so those are two things
that are
really really expensive to do and they
do not lend themselves very easily to
being automatically done on a massive
scale across a quarter million of these
metrics so
um that's a that's a really big problem
because then you're you know you're
dealing with
models that don't even fit your data and
you're trying to detect anomalies with
those models and when it's not feasible
to to hand fit all your models to data
what do you do
this is a problem that we're dealing
with and so you can't have good
anomalies without good models and so um
as you might have guessed a robust set
of algorithms is the current focus of
this project
we've got the architecture pretty much
set um it's not distributed yet it runs
on one box and we want to keep it that
way ideally but um but yeah so the the
the hard part now and this is gonna take
a while but the hard part now is just
figuring out how to solve these problems
um with our models and with our
algorithms and with our data
[Applause]